Rebecca is in Tampa Florida hi Rebecca
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you so much for taking my call
it's such an honor to talk to you you
too what's up I'm a huge fan I just
finished a PU I'm a single mom of five
I'm debt free as in my mortgage but I'm
actually calling you about my twin
sister
we we are about to inherit some money my
father's wife just passed away and you
know his trust is going to be dispersed
we're about to inherit about a hundred
between hundred ten 115,000 my sister
yes each there's other errors too
actually though it's being split four
ways okay but she's kind of the black
sheep of the family um we've had
inheritance before she squandered it and
now she's talking about getting one of
those advance inheritance loans because
she she just can taste the money already
and she can't wait however long it's
going to take for the trust to be
disbursed she's a lot of plans for the
money she wants by home she wants to go
back to school
there's her degree she needs teeth
because her she needs a full set of
dentures and I just don't know what to
do I don't know how to talk her out of
getting this inheritance advance loan I
can't give her any more money I'm a
single mom of five everybody giving her
like a thousand dollars help her out
and so I need help I need to figure out
how to help her ease away without
enabling her
well you're not enabling her because
you're not giving her any money I did
though yeah you're not getting you're
not giving her anymore under any
circumstances because you're just giving
a drunk a drink
you're not helping you're not helping
her by giving her money so I learned
that after I started following you and
after I finished up to you I'm like I
like giving her any more money yeah
because it's not loving I mean you're
because you're assisting her in her
delusions all right so she doesn't want
your opinion though right no but this
your last chance I mean little bit but
you want you want her to win more than
she wants to win yeah you just can't you
can't make people that are grownups and
are you know unless they're insane and
the court appoints someone to watch over
them you can't make other adults make
decisions all you can do is attempt to
persuade and I don't have any magic
persuasion beans on disability for
mental illness actually enough that you
could get the courts to not give her the
money and manage somebody manage it for
her it's possible I know she wouldn't be
very happy but I'm not the executor our
older sister is the executor mm-hmm ask
your ago an older sister to see if you
can have what's called a guardian ad
litem reported to bat on behalf of your
sister because she's been declared
mentally ill what's the nature of her
mental illness um she claims that it's
um a post-traumatic stress disorder but
a more infamous I don't believe that
that's her real diagnosis I think she
has histrionic Personality Disorder no
I'm trying to get her to take your
course oh why - women you said dentures
how you don't sound that old how old are
you I'm were twins and I'm 38 she's 38
fine she already lost underneath she
drug addict he is never taking care of
her teeth she just has everything or
brush your teeth over just that simple
so where did he live she lives out of
her car in Houston Texas
so she's homeless if she's homeless yeah
and she collects a disability check from
the government due to mental disability
yeah I think you can make a case that
she's not capable of handling this money
okay um and that and it be managed not
for not that one of you steal the money
I don't mean that but that the money be
managed by a third party that manages it
for her good and that could be appointed
it doesn't need to be you it needs to be
your older sister or it needs to be an
attorney that's in the mix here
you think maybe applying that money
towards a home I think that anybody
getting this money but her and handling
it on her behalf is a better thing you
do - the only question is whether the
court can
you know whether the court will look at
this and declare her mentally
incompetent to handle it and as she need
assistance from a third party that's
appointed by the court that's called a
guardian ad litem in most states I'm not
an attorney but I've been involved in
these things enough times that sadly
that that's what happens here so you
know and you're going to everybody that
is involved in this she's going to be
mad at you for the rest of your life but
that's okay because you're taking care
of her right it's just not enough money
to really take care of her for the rest
of her life it's not enough money doing
anything she wants to do hardly right um
but if the you know if we wanted to deal
it out on a monthly basis to help her
get a place to live and get out of her
car but she probably makes enough off
the government to do that doesn't she
she does but she Swan does it on
cigarettes and you know soda yeah it's
unfortunate I think she does probably
have a mental illness at this stage of
the game yeah it's bad enough that she's
debilitated I'm not a mental health
professional but it just got all the
it's got all the telltale signs I mean
she's living in the car to the point
that she's lost her teeth and her you
know she's living she's squandering the
money that she has and this money is
going to all be gone I mean she's going
to lose it she may even just get robbed
and get his stolen from her on a cash
basis now let me just tell you this if
the court doesn't do that and if you all
choose as a family not to pursue that
and ask the court to do that on her
behalf and instead the money is just
given to her I would give you a 1%
chance you can talk her into anything
you did not describe a person to me that
can be persuaded by wisdom yeah and
that's what that's your only shot is to
persuade her by wisdom right I'm trying
to get her to take your course but she's
not interested oh no of course she's not
but she's not I mean she's a she's
pretty messed up I mean and I just I
don't know if there's enough solid
material there to to get ahold of to
really lead her well out of this
I mean without somebody doing some
intensive counseling and really getting
inside of her head you know that's
probably what she needs to spend her
money on and she needs to get tied into
a good church get her a little basic
apartment
spend time healing her mental wounds
that have got our news point and get her
back where she's functional again and
then talk about going to school but I
don't think she's got the ability to
complete large tasks like school she
doesn't she's quit every job and every
education she's over China and she's a
perpetual victim when you talk to her
exactly everything everybody's done to
get her there's a paranoia that goes
with this right yeah yeah this week sad
yeah I've dealt with it a lot it's just
it's really really sad but so you know
the question is what do we need for her
we need healing for her she won't go to
church I took her Church with me one
since she should she listen she's gonna
do a lot of things if this money is held
back until she does them true but what
we can hope for her and pray for her is
that the money is held back and used for
her counseling and that she's required
to plug into a basic lifestyle like I
live like a human not an animal because
she's making choices here that are doing
this yeah and we've got to get her up
you know get her back into the human
race again and don't you ever give her
another dime the rest of your life
I know and that would be I would be
looking at it listen if you give her
money you might as well look at her and
say I hate you right because that's what
you're doing she's not welcome in my
that's not what I mean
admit you're doing her harm by giving
her money yeah I'm not giving her any
more money every yeah all right so get
with your cistern you guys decide if you
want to have her declared incompetent
and I think there's a possibility of
doing that I don't know you'd have to
talk to an attorney a lot smarter than
me but it would be an act of mercy to
her to lead her into some good
counseling into a good church home into
a situation where her mind and her
spirit can be rebuilt and she can begin
to be functional again and then let her
have the pieces of the money to go to
school or pieces of the money to go to
buy a home those aren't bad goals but
you're just describing someone to me
that's very very very broken and wounded
and it's very sad and you've got to help
the whole person you can't just throw
money at it
folks your eyes that when the government
throws money at these problems that's
that that's how that's why doesn't work
right there you just heard it if you
understood that call in my response to
it and you understand my government
programs for these things don't work
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you